all right so the first look and trailer
for marvel's werewolf by night is now
out and throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down the easter
eggs in it some comic lore theories and
our general thoughts on this first
marvel studios one-off halloween special
so we had been hearing rumors about this
for roughly a year and it's cool to
actually see this first marvel special
because of its older black and white
style that's not necessarily fitting in
with the mcu standard while being
labeled a comedy there is no shortage of
graphic horror elements in this tv 14
rating i've gotta give a hand to marvel
for shaking it up because i am already
dancing in the moonlight anyway we're
gonna be going over all of it but also
there's going to be some heavy spoilers
pun intended in this video due to some
of the characters that we've heard about
there's also going to be a few potential
rumors about how these characters tie in
with some of the future mcu properties
so if you don't want that to be
potentially ruined then i recommend that
you turn this off now with that out of
the way a howling thank you for clicking
this now let's get into werewolf by
night
[Music]
now the trailer first opens on this new
marvel studio special presentation title
screen and to my understanding werewolf
by night is going to be the first of a
handful of these upcoming specials i'm
curious what the run time of this is
going to be but rumors have it kind of
slided for a run time of somewhere
between 45 and 50 minutes with the style
of a 30s or 40s black and white film
heavy on the film grain and real burn
with the cliched movie announcer setting
the tone and feel we are then quickly
introduced to the plot revolving around
a handful of monster hunters all hunting
an unknown threat that is actually
hiding in plain sight as one of the
other hunters
tonight
it is every hunter for
themselves but one of you is a monster
masquerading as one of our own
the official synopsis adds more details
into this stating that all of these
hunters gather at bloodstone castle
following the death of their leader and
engage in a deadly competition for a
powerful relic and we'll touch on what
could potentially be that so-called
powerful relic later but around the room
we get glimpses of the other hunters of
which is harriet sansom harris as varusa
who appears to be the leader of this
cabal laura donnelly as elsa bloodstone
who is the famed monster hunter and
daughter of ulysses bloodstone who seems
to be the talking corpse in the coffin
or at least the voice over is from him
according to the subtitles so it's
probably ulysses bloodstone's death that
brings them all back for the night we
also see a handful of other monster
hunters all sporting the same pendant to
show that they are in the same clan of
hunters unfortunately i couldn't figure
out who these four characters are aside
from this dude with the beard named
joven because it's shown in the
subtitles so if you are a smarty pants
drop their names in the comments and let
paul know that i am a chump and the man
needs to fire me yet again and lastly
gael garcia bernal aka jack russell aka
werewolf by night who i'm sure is going
to be doing this the entire time yeah
we're all trying to find the guy who did
this now some comic backstory on this
character shows us that jack russell is
well well he's a werewolf i mean what
what else do you want to know
essentially a descendant of russell has
been inflicted by a werewolf's curse
centuries earlier when fighting dracula
and therefore passed on from generation
to generation making russell the current
werewolf by night his origins are a bit
messy ranging from almost a teen wolf
approach with him finding out about his
powers when he turns 18 to his ancestors
having been involved with finding pages
to the darkhold that we've seen in you
know multiverse of madness when turning
into the savage werewolf he possesses
all of the traits and abilities you'd
think that comes along with it obviously
silver being his one big weakness he
does lose his intellect in this
transformation becoming this savage
beast however years later russell is
able to hone in on this allowing his
intellect to stay with him when this
transformation happens similar to what
we saw was done with smart hulk in end
game getting back into the trailer it
appears that the hunt will take up a
majority of the story but there are also
a handful of things that have really
kind of interested me from this trailer
because there is a quick shot of man
thing attacking some of the hunters in a
maze if you didn't know in the comics
man thing used to be dr theodor salus
who was a biochemist working in the
everglades attempting to recreate the
super soldier serum how after aim tried
to steal his research he injects himself
with this serum crashes his car into a
magical swamp and then ends up turning
it into a slow-moving swamp monster
called man thing it's later revealed
that the magical swamp is a nexus to all
realities essentially a pathway to any
and all realities like a reality where
this did not happen ah my eyes and man
thing essentially becomes its guardian
so it could potentially be man thing who
is the monster everyone is actually
hunting rather than jack russell or he's
the bigger antagonist of this special
however another thing that very much
raises a lot of questions is the
appearance of tva agents if you take a
closer look at who werewolf by night is
fighting and who locked elsa into the
cage the outfits of these guards or i
guess intruders have a striking
similarity to the tva agents that we saw
in loki season 1. so the fact that they
are here has me wondering if one or
multiple events that are happening in
this story cause a nexus event or that
the tva is trying to get rid of man
thing to have control over the nexus of
realities and shout out to the nerd doc
on youtube for making this connection
but the powerful relic that all of the
hunters are in a competition for could
be the bloodstone gem in the comics
ulysses bloodstone originally possessed
this later passing it on to his daughter
elsa this gem gives its wearer a whole
bevy of abilities from superhuman
strength and speed to psychic abilities
and immortality think the philosopher's
stone but like um
way cooler this would explain why all of
the hunters are called back whoever
finds the relic becomes the new leader
of the bloodstone hunter clan with man
thing essentially being the final boss
who is protecting it anyway this first
look at werewolf by night has me
instantly excited out of all of the d23
announcements and trailers this one has
kind of stuck with me over the last few
days the fact that marvel's leaning into
these kind of one-off specials is
something that intrigues me but for this
one it is entirely the different style
that we haven't seen in the mcu or we
haven't seen them explore yet like this
feels and looks like a 1930s and 40s
universal monster movie from the
cinematography editing style the voice
over even the cheesy humor of i'll be
rotting for you but also it doesn't look
like it's going to be holding back
because the tva agents or whoever the
heck they are are getting torn up in
some graphic looking bloodshed and the
final nail in the coffin is michael
giaccino directing this frightfest he
might not be the most well-known in the
directing side of things but his
composing talents are unmatched so i'm
curious how much free reign marvel gave
him for this special this one-off
special could be setting up a much
larger section of supernatural beans in
the mcu that i am 100 on board for say
they continue this trend with a dracula
movie potentially ghost rider or black
knight hell even mephisto and then weave
these together in the bigger mcu budget
features like blade eventually leading
to a team-up film forming the midnight
suns sure this is wishful thinking but
with the positive reception of moon
knight and the first reactions of
werewolf by night there is something to
be mined here and get real get just
weird with things i love 2003's league
of extraordinary gentlemen because of
the supernatural fantasy team-up dynamic
so make it happen kevin feige i want to
see a vampire and a werewolf and hell
even frankenstein just punch people in
the face plus you can rub it in
universal's face with their failed dooku
you remember that the dark universe
cinematic universe that was supposed to
do exactly what i'm wishing for here you
know this picture
never forget
[Music]
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on this new marvel special so comment
below and let me know we're currently
running a competition giving away three
copies of top gun maverick on the 15th
of september and all you have to do to
be in a chance for winning this is like
this video make sure to subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on this trailer
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so if
that's you message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch check out our episode 4
breakdown of she-hulk or also our season
six coverage of rick and morty click one
right over there you know you want to
with all of that out of the way thanks
for sticking through this video i've
been jared and i'll see you next time
take care and peace